this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn ryan nicodemus
is on vacation but don't worry i have
two people in the studio with me
today my lovely wife rebecca sharon is
here from minimal wellness
and and then we have joel green is here
the author of this new book which i'll
hold up if you're watching on youtube
it's called the immunity code and i
can't wait to to dive into this because
today we're going to talk about what it
really means
to eat in a balanced way we're going to
talk about improving our immune systems
we're going to talk about why our
overall health is related to gut health
and we have a whole lot more to talk
about and a bunch of your questions to
answer
as well joel thanks for joining us today
thank you thank you for having me yeah
man this book is fascinating uh
you know bex is a registered dietitian
and nutritionist and
she's been helping me dive in to the
all of the knowledge that is packed in
into this book
and i'm really fascinated by this
because a lot of it seems intuitive
but then also a lot of the stuff is
these are things i haven't heard before
why is that yeah that's it's an
interesting one
um there i get that a lot yeah about the
book but why haven't i heard that before
it makes so much sense i haven't heard
it
and um i think part of it it part part
of the answer is kind of like heard
heard behavior like you know people in
crowds do dumb stuff the bigger the
crowd the dumber the stuff
so accurate so we we've um
we just have kind of a kind of a herd
that
in terms when it comes to fitness in our
bodies and we've kind of gone this one
direction
and we've all gone it i've gone it we've
all done it
and like when you peel it back and go
wait wait why are we doing this this way
and you start to think about it you come
up with
i don't know why are we doing it this
way yeah it doesn't make a lot of sense
yeah and so there's there's kind of that
going on um i think another
aspect to it is that um when
every now and then uh when you go a
particular direction in in a paradigm
you kind of get to the end of that
paradigm and then what can happen
is um new information can come along
and it kind of snaps us back to center
and then you realize
wow we were really off center we didn't
think that we were
and i think there's some of that going
on in there too um a lot of let's talk
about some of the information that's in
the book because
uh the way you describe it is an
entirely new way to think about caring
for the body
and the book is called the immunity code
let's talk about
what's important about the immune system
we obviously are starting to hear talk
about the immune system now in the
context of
viruses and and fighting off viruses
but let's talk about what the immune
system is and why it's so important
well the first thing to understand is
that um we have this concept of
immunity sort of as an ancillary thing
like it's this
it's this sort of thing in a bottle that
you know you you
oh i just need some zinc and some
vitamin d and there now i've got it now
i have immunity
and it's this idea that like there's a
christmas tree and immunity is another
ornament on the tree
that's kind of the idea and when you
begin to like really like dive down into
mechanistically like how the body works
and look at like the mechanisms in the
body what you come up with is that
actually no immunity is the tree and
everything else is the ornaments
it's the foundation and so um we have
this idea of immunity that you know it's
it's sort of like um ancillarized into
well take this and that now you've got
it
and when you really begin to work
through how to have real immunity it
begins to touch everything it touches
every part of the body
so it touches body fat in fact
it turns out that actually immunity
governs body fat like
wow yeah immune mechanisms govern body
fat
things like very specific immune cells
immune signals they all govern body fat
and then when you look at the gut and
you look at like what governs the gut
well it's really immune mechanisms that
govern the gut
and every part of the body you find this
is true when you look at aging it turns
out that aging actually really is
you can best describe aging sort of like
as a you know
the body begins to treat um with age
begins to act like age itself is just an
injury
it's just a systemic system-wide injury
that never resolves
and so you begin to see that immunity is
the foundation and the mechanisms that
are in immunity are the foundation
of everything else in the body and so
that's a different shift
that's really fascinating so especially
with the covid
epidemic right now do you think the
younger population because of the
the large prevalence of people who are
overweight and obese
like is that what's driving the the
immune issue there but
at an older age it's a different
mechanism yeah that is a fantastic
question
um and actually very accurate um so what
you see is
so first let's start with people who are
elder elderly populations
what you see with elderly populations
and sort of susceptibility to things
like covet
is that they are in a constant state of
what we would call sort of oxidative
stress
okay or redox imbalance and what that
really kind of points to
is that you know your body has a sort of
a natural
system for balancing sort of you know
free radicals antioxidants
and when the natural reductive systems
in the body get stressed so things like
glutathione peroxidase catalase
superoxide dismusing when those things
get overworked and stressed
then the body gets into what's known as
oxidative stress meaning it's just
trying to keep
up and so what you see with older
populations with like age populations
is you see that um they're kind of in a
sort of a persistent state of oxidative
stress from what we call inflammation
or rather like an overactivation of the
inflammasome and so meaning they have
this kind of like
essentially what is an immune reaction
you know the way the way that immunity
typically works is you have
sort of this initial recruitment or
onset of you know kind of first
responders
these are things like um very specific
types of macrophages and
secretory iga very specific types of
antibodies
and then in the process of resolving an
injury or an attack on the body
those things have to go away and then a
different aspect of the immune system
has to kick in
and resolution happens what we see in
older populations
is is they never get to that state
they're just in this constant state of
what we would call kind of
the first responders being there um and
so
these are things like you know
centalytic cells
um over activation of very specific
immune signals
and so they're inoxidative stress and
it's that oxidative stress
that lends itself out to susceptibility
to things like covid19 because when you
look at like very healthy populations
they kind of have more or less a redox
balance they're they're in balance
with sort of the the reductive capacity
of their body
and so what you see is like with code 19
that it has a much more difficult time
docking has a much more difficult time
getting hold
um to the cell membrane to the ace
receptor it's because they're in redox
balance
so it never really gets underway now
when you look at obese populations you
see something very similar that gets
really interesting
so what you see with obese populations
is they have
very similar issues in terms of
inflammation
and in particular inflammation of body
fat so what you see is that when body
fat um
becomes inflamed it acts like a giant
megaphone
and it affects the entire body
especially as you age
so body fat is kind of a crux variable
in regulating
and modulating inflammatory signals
across the entire body
and the really sort of interesting
revelation that's
that's come down the pike over the last
few years is that weight cycling
can spawn the same thing so you know oh
i'm fat i got to do something about it
you know
go on a diet lose some weight and then
ooh rebounding rebounding
well what happens over time by doing
that is you actually begin to stress
the extracellular matrix that holds your
fat in place
and it gets stiffer and as it gets
stiffer it takes on an inflamed profile
and then inflamed profile just magnifies
inflammatory signals across the body
so inflammation often has to do with an
overactive immune system
let's talk about how controlling
inflammation
is really the key to to good health to
longevity etc
well that's a fantastic point um
so when you look at um different
theories of aging
there's a lot of them like a whole bunch
and a lot of them don't agree
okay um um but
some of the newer theories there i
talked about one in the book called
remodeling theory there's another one
called network theory
some of the newer theories really kind
of look at the aspects
of immunity where the immune mechanisms
and immune signals that govern
inflammation get over-subscribed
sort of over-activated and so when we
begin to ask well how can we kind of
dial this down
how can we kind of flip the switch here
right um what we come to quickly is
that it's it's a tissue by tissue
proposition
like we actually have to look at an
order of operations and we have to look
at well wait
where where does where's all this kind
of beginning and it quickly leads us to
well
really you know the gums and the gut are
kind of the first place that we have to
start
because that's kind of where immunity
begins in the body the body comes into
contact with the outside world
first in the gums and then in the gut
lining and so
that becomes kind of the first step and
it's a very different
proposition from the rest of the body so
when you look at
immunity in the gut uh it's it's it's
quite a rabbit hole
and it gets interesting super fast um
start talking about the microbiome right
away
yeah um what's interesting and where
where i
i don't know if i did a great job i
tried to in the book um
what gets very interesting very fast is
that
you have to begin to um unsubscribe from
a lot of
uh paradigms that we have kind of bought
into in this age that we're in
like diversity is the key to the adverse
gut microbiome is the key to gut health
that's not necessarily true
i'm learning that from your book right
well this way to put that is
um diversity is important um but
pursuing diversity uh isn't gonna get
you there okay um
like like we have this idea that
diversity you know is kind of
the the end-all be-all in the gut and
while it is true that you know
the gut itself needs to have sort of a
diverse biome in the gut
um pursuing diversity is not a strategy
it's going to it's not going to work
it's not going to get you anywhere you
can get
much more bang for the buck by pursuing
a couple of bacteria than you would by
pursuing diversity
uh those are acromancia bifida bacteria
right acromancy
alpha and bifidobacteria as a family
yeah okay yeah let's talk a little bit
about both of those
why they're important yeah so um a
couple reasons one um
let's back up and start with like kind
of um let's start with like a picture of
health and like
the leanest healthiest longest lived
people and let's look at kids like
when you're young when you're very
energetic and kind of what that looks
like and
what we seem to what seems to be the
case
is that when you're young you have high
populations of bifidobacteria
and before bacteria is very interesting
for a number of reasons
one of those is that it really seems to
control
a whole lot of things that are involved
in keeping the body lean
specifically there is a there's a key
protein called an angioprotein
angio anglp4 or or fascinating induced
adipose factor
and it's it's controlled by
photobacteria
um this protein uh suppresses
lipoprotein lipase
so it actually has a lot to do with the
body's ability to store fat and not
store fat
so as our bodies um as we're young when
we're young we have higher populations
of before bacteria
the photobacteria is also involved in
making b vitamins um
and and what really gets interesting is
when you begin to look at different
kinds of diseases and you start to look
at things like
um parkinson's and crohn's and things
like that and you see these correlations
to low
low photobacteria populations um that's
really interesting and then sort of
anecdotally speaking
what you see happen is when you begin to
restore these things you see the
symptomology of these things
lessen significantly and rapidly like
very fast i've personally witnessed it
let's talk about how do how do we
restore these things so so
whether it's bifido or acromancy i mean
there you have some
sort of hacks in in the book um the
apple peel thing is is fascinating bex
has been doing this for a few weeks now
you want to talk about that oh wow yeah
okay yeah i just finished it
i just was like i'm cool with the apple
peel let's hear it
yeah so i did the apple peels i kind of
like did an extended version of
the protocol that you have in the book
just because like
i i felt like my health had not been
quite where it should be i've been
struggling with shingles
of all things um for like the last
six eight months and i so i was like i
really need to like
dive into this uh the series of
protocols that you have so yeah i did an
extended version of the
the apple peel protocol so i did the
apple peels for several weeks and then
added the hmo
um and then the reds how did you feel on
that great
yeah yeah did you feel energetic on it
yeah i'll talk about what hmo is
yeah so the human milk saccharide by the
way it's good you keep asking questions
because i will rant
he won't shut up he's still talking he's
a very good host
[Laughter]
let's talk about what hmo is and why we
would incorporate yeah so
yeah so uh hmo uh what's called human
milk oligosaccharides um
it's like a little spray we got from
amazon that's one way to get it yeah
that's one way
uh so basically they are they are
essentially
um they're essentially they're
glycoproteins their carbohydrates bound
to protein they're found in mother's
milk
and they they have a whole heck of a lot
to do with establishing immunity
in the infant gut um and they affect a
lot of things in some very interesting
ways
would you also get this from colostrum
yeah you can get you can get hmo in
colostrum
um the frac you're gonna get different
fractions and the amounts and things can
vary
there's about 200 different known hmos
there's there's roughly just a couple
right now they're actually on the market
but they seem to have some very
remarkable properties um with respect to
restoring the gut
and helping the gut one of the things we
have to look at is if you want to
establish immunity in the gut you have
to look at how immunity began
in the gut and the way immunity began in
the gut was you got mother's milk
you got mother's milk and mother's milk
were these things and these things do
some
very interesting things they act as
decoys um
for different kinds of like um pathogens
um so that they there's a thing called a
histo blood group antigen
and hmos actually mimic these
structurally so they actually
uh can prevent things from binding to
the mucosa of the gut lining
um mucosa is just the outer layer of
just the inner lining yeah the inner
lining of the gut um
they can actually prevent different
types of things pathogens from binding
to that
and they also help to stimulate the
phytobacteria in the gut
so um if we were to look at like well
what can we look at to
to like if we were to build the perfect
human gut where would we start and
there's a short list that comes up
quickly we need aminos uh for a number
of different reasons and we probably
want to throw in hmos
and then we'd probably want to throw in
very specific phenols um
very specific phenols so we would get
those from like dark fruits
dark fruits yeah um blueberries
strawberries
uh yeah so there's a there's a few
things going on there um blackberries
blueberry strawberries
there are phenols in there anthocyanins
things like that and
those are food for bifidobacteria and
then specific to apple peels in the
protocol that you did
what you find is that there's very
interesting
molecules that are in the the skin
themselves of apple peels
there's what's called a highly highly
polymerized procyanidin
and they're basically long story short
there's these massive massive massive
like sugar molecules
that just don't break down because
they're so big and so they sit in the
gut and they ferment and they just
happen to ferment in the right place
and acromancia feeds on those things so
like as a cocktail um when we look at
like red phenols apple peels and hmos
um it's a pretty good cocktail you know
now you you often talk about order of
operation and how important that is
because
and to me it makes sense the analogy i
would use like if you bake a cake but
you do it in the wrong order
you're going to screw everything up
right
and and so what i've noticed about this
is like it would be really convenient if
you could just say well here's the list
of 12 things you take these and you're
good to go it's like
what's sort of that but it's also like
you have to
do this in the right order so the apple
peel thing was
i believe a first step in in in many
respects to try to
increase the the acromancia in the gut
right
yes that was the the so the way to look
at it is like changing the oil when
people come into the book the very first
thing is like
most of us have issues in the gut and we
don't really even know it or we do know
it and we can't do anything about it
and so let me just say those issues
could manifest in different ways some
people see it as
a gluten intolerance per se or a dairy
intolerance
or uh even a intolerance to fiber
right yes so so how do these things
manifest and then what's the order of
operations to start addressing these oh
my gosh talk about a rant here it comes
let's do it prepare your representatives
well all right so what's been so you
asked me up front why
why why haven't i heard this before um i
think one reason
is that we have um we have a culture
that has
really subscribed to narrative as a way
to explain things
and i love narrative sure you know
narrative's great narrative is very
powerful
um we can learn a lot from narratives
every now and then though you need to go
to the structure function of something
you know like like a narrative would be
you know it's a tesla and you stomp on
it and it has a 10-4 quarter
okay and you'll smoke everything but
mechanistically it would be
well it's got an electric drive and it
goes into the motor the motor sits right
next to the wheel and the reason it's so
fast is because you have torque that's
instantly you know and you get into the
mechanisms right okay
so every now and then you need to break
the mechanisms down that's never been
done nobody's really broken the
mechanisms down of
why your question is relevant so
mechanistically when you begin to look
at this
um and i'm just going to i'm kind of
going to cover this in a broad sense but
i think it's really important because
people need to understand
mechanistically why these things happen
so when you look at the inside of the
gut okay
what you quickly see is that the lining
of the gut
is different from any other place in the
body what's really different is that it
exists in a
super oxidized state that's normal for
the gut
and so because of that it's
mechanistically has very specific
particulars meaning things like um
immune cells
that normally would encounter a a very
specific immune signal like
interleukin-1b
and would just set off a four-fire alarm
they don't do anything in the gut when
they see that
so they are attenuated to the oxidative
environment of the gut lining
highly oxidized highly think of it in
terms of like you know
highly oxidized oxidation is like rust
think of the engine of a car
inside the engine of a car it's it's
really hot and combustive
but there's something that protects it
and that thing is oil right so as long
as you have oil the engine works
right okay so what protects the inside
of the gut lining from that oxidation is
a square bait
so you have a lot of square bait in the
gut lining and so it buffers
the highly oxidative environment in the
gut lining okay
that's normally now when it's operating
normally
what you have is that um in the colon a
lot of the body's digestion gets done
and in the colon
there's a very special fat called
butyrate
that allows those cells within the colon
to feed
they live on butyrate and when
when everything's working fine the way
things work in the gut is that butyrate
is the main fuel
inside of there okay but what happens is
when the gut gets deprived over very
long periods of the raw
materials it needs what begins to happen
is
the ascorbate in the gut layer gets bled
down
okay the wrist it's like the motor oil
in the car bleeds dry
and when that happens the engine gets
worn out so when a score bait and the
gut lining gets bled
down what happens is a key point comes
where
a switch gets turned and what happens is
the
gut lining stops using butyrate okay
because it can't use it anymore the key
transporter it's called mct one
switches off at the same time a sugar
transporter switches on that's called
the glut1
okay when that turns on what happens
is the inside of the gut lining
uh begins to look like cancer
it starts to resemble cancer chemically
when you look at what's going on
so what goes on the layman call this
leaky gut or
are we there yeah we're just about there
okay okay what happens is
butyrate makes a uh hits a signal
molecule called interleukin-10
keeps the gut shut keeps the colon shut
in the gut okay
when when butyrate stops working in the
gut
and the gut begins to use sugar which is
a backup fuel it can use sugar for a
while
but not for long periods when it begins
to use sugar for very long periods what
begins to happen in the gut
is that the inner lining of the gut gets
highly highly oxidized and gets damaged
so
just think about the motor oil is not
working anymore okay
when it begins to get damaged suddenly
the gut starts to open up
okay um so you get a different
interleukin called interleukin-6 signals
the gut to open up begins to open up
and now what you start to see are all
these sort of inflammatory issues and we
have different names for these you know
you have colitis and crunchy
all these different names for these um
and so
when that happens now you get a problem
that begins to spiral and get bigger and
what we see a lot is this
um at that point the body can no longer
handle fiber
okay so you think this is where i am
right now yeah yeah you think fiber is
the solution
but at that point the fiber trans
put it this way the way to think of it
is that the end product of fiber is
butyrate
that transporter's down can't work right
so when you feed the gut fiber it gets
worse
yeah okay so at that point what you'll
see people do is they'll things they'll
they're thinking oh well i heard the
carnivore diet it's gonna go on that
yeah so they'll go on a carnivore diet
and then what happens is you have a
short-term long-term effect
short-term effect is aminos are
incredibly healing on the gut for a
number of reasons we need aminos
so what happens is the sensation
cessation of fiber
addition of aminos has a has a healing
effect on the gut
so the gut oh you mean amino acids yes
from protein yes
so you hear this phrase meat heals super
true super true but
but mechanistically the reason is
because of amino acids
so you have amino acids in the gut like
glutamine you have arginine you have all
these different amino acids what they do
is
um they are very healing on the gut and
they affect different immune mechanisms
so if
you see an amelioration of the irritants
fiber
because the fiber transports not working
but now you have a bigger problem right
the bigger problem you have now
is that you still need butyrate gut
still needs butyrate and it's still
going to make it right
so the gut has two ways to make butyrate
one is by what's called sarcolytic
fermentation meaning
carbs so here's what you get on this
side of the equation this is the carb
side
on the carb side of the equation you get
two end products
one is what's called your short chain
fatty acids okay
and the other basically is sort of
phenolic compounds which more or less
equate to antioxidants as your output
okay okay so you get antioxidants here
and you're gonna get short chain fatty
acids here
okay the trick here is the ratios
is is everything so what happens is when
you're making butyrate from carbs
um as you're coming down the daisy chain
of converting into acetyl coa and
converting that into butyrate eventually
what happens
is there's a feedback loop that happens
and this is critical
in that feedback loop you're going to
get acetate butyrate pn8
acetate gets re-salvaged back into
acetyl-coa and makes more butyrate
so at the end of that you get butyrate a
little bit of acetate
moderate amount of ph for pna that's
super important
and then with that you get essentially
antioxidants
okay now when you shove that out of the
way and you're making amino acids from
protein
you've got two ways you can go one is
what's basically the ketogenic path
okay and on that path
there's no salvage path back from
acetate into acetoacetate okay
so what you're going to end up with is
um
higher ratios of acetate lower ratios of
butyrate
and then higher ratios of propionate
that's super important because
acetate um basically helps the body
store fat in fact it's why you get fatty
liver for the most part
um and they affect the gut lining very
different ways
and your your your second output from
all that
is ammonia so on this side of the
equation your secondary output were
ultimately phenols and antioxidants
here it's ammonia okay so you don't have
the phenols in antioxidants
so what happens when you're doing that
is ammonia
begins to interact with things in the
gut and you can get
essentially excessive alkane alkylation
in the gut
and the protein itself ferments very
differently from carbs
so what you're going to get is protein
fermentation protein fermentation in the
gut
generally is cancerous generally
speaking you can offset it with fiber
but now by itself in the short term it's
not that big a deal
um and so that's why you see temporarily
you get this healing effect
sure like oh i went on this carnivore
thing and i feel very healed it's
removing of symptoms though
right right fasting does the same thing
yeah that's not a sustainable diet
right but in perpetuity you can't fast
no but where is that that leading us
though you actually brought something
very stupid which
is that um fasting does replete the gut
and it does it basically through what is
known as endogenous
nitrogen production meaning you're
making nitrogen internally so
that later on we'll come back to this
that can be combined
with this side of the equation over here
so you can combine that once you fix the
gut you can combine that with fibers
and now you've got the best of both
worlds yeah okay but back on this side
of the equation here
when you're making uh butyrate via the
via protein fermentation via the
ketogenic pathway
at the end of the day um term you're
creating an issue
because of the way that you're
fermenting proteins
that's an issue because you got to look
at the types of bacteria that ferment
the end products they make you get these
what are known as nitroso compounds that
can interact and you get these
essentially cancer-forming compounds in
the gut the other side of that equation
is you can make protein by what's called
the gluconeogenic pathway you can make
butyrate via that pathway now by that
pathway
we have some advantages it's very
similar to making
short chain fatty acids from carbs okay
but again
your end product is not phenols
antioxidants and short chain fatty acids
your end product
is short chain fatty acids and ammonia
it's a very different equation because
over time the antioxidants and phenols
that need to buffer the acidity
in the gut lining aren't there right
okay so the longer you do that
you start to see autoimmune issues and
different things like that sure
so we are interested in the crohn's
disease but it's also it could be
skin issues eczema all these other
things that result from that as well
yeah and
long story short it all comes from
imbalances in the diet
yeah and really i think that's the what
i'm learning from your book is
is what we're really talking about is is
is balancing
yeah uh not just the gut but balancing
our health
because anything out of balance is
unhealthy like water's healthy for you
except when it's out of balance and now
it's unhealthy right
yeah yeah yeah it's just people like
what's the secret to your book and i'm
like ah it's called the balanced diet
look
that's not a secret there's nothing new
there i'm like yeah nothing new i know
right except except in fact that leads
me to a question we have here from
rachel we're usually
a listener driven show so let me just
pop this in here what are the best foods
for gut health now we've talked about a
lot of these things already you've
talked about
apple peels you've talked about
blueberry strawberries blackberries
um orange juice i know that you you talk
about being
uh healing and i assume it's because of
ascorbic acid right
yeah um so so those are some things
there what else
what what is what is helpful for
the gut and later during the maximal i
think we'll get into the the order of
operation on things
but let's let's just talk about some
foods that are that are healing and
healthy that we haven't already touched
upon
yeah so assumption is that you are you
are
past the point of the inflamed gut
because a lot of the things that are
very healthy for the gut in an ongoing
basis you can't give
up front when you've got all these sort
of issues so if someone has crohn's
disease for example or
or colitis um or ulcers
what's healthy for them is going to be
different from what's healthy for the
person with your
average gut it's like you said there's
an order of operations yeah yeah
yeah so they're going to need aminos and
and things like the hmos up front
and then and then you sort of baby step
your way back into fibers
okay yeah okay but generally speaking um
things that are healthy for the gut
long term would be things like resistant
starch um
foods that have phenols so anything with
colors like dark colors in it
let's talk about resistant starches
because i was listening to an interview
you did another podcast and you had the
most hilarious chipotle hack yeah um
when he goes to chipotle he he puts ice
in the b
he gets the beans separate and puts ice
in them it's a great cove at attention
strategy like if you're if you just
spend too much time alone you just go to
chipotle go to the ice machine and
everybody's like
what are you doing they think oh this
crazy guy's putting
ice in his beans because they've never
seen someone do that but there's a
strategy behind that it's not that you
like cold beans necessarily
it's that they do something different in
the gut uh what other foods are like
that besides you know the
the cold black beans potatoes okay some
potatoes uh
cold potatoes yeah yeah in fact there's
a there are you can look this up there's
potato diets out there where people
eat nothing potatoes and get ripped yeah
on potatoes yeah okay
potatoes with potatoes do that just
generally speaking garbanzo beans are
fantastic
probably the probably like your vegan
garbanzos would be my top of the list
because they have so much protein in
them but they also have
very special long chain carbs in them
that are
very sensitizing for insulin so they're
kind of a wonder food
for um both body fat and for the gut
they're very very effective yeah
but only cold right is that the key well
the difference to think of it is this
way um there's a state
in which certain resistant starches um
don't feed you
they feed the bacteria in their gut and
then there's a state where they feed you
so in one state um a lot of different
kinds of resistant starches when they're
cold or cooled down
um the the food in them is really not
digestible by you
not all but most of it and you're
feeding the gut
you don't get a lot of energy from it
but when you heat them up those long
chain
starch chains break down into simple
sugars and then it feeds you
gotcha yeah man there's so many things i
want to talk about here on the minimal
before we wrap this up let's talk about
eating in threes really quickly
i found this to be fascinating and since
i've made some changes recently
it's amazing how my satiety is affected
by my previous meal
and it took me 40 years to figure that
out right yeah
talk to me about that yeah well so
there's this really new
uh fascinating body of research um that
has to do with meal to meal sequencing
and it's very science-based and we're
just simply looking at
the effect that a previous meal will
have on the next meal and
and you can look at all these parameters
of the previous meal so you can look at
what was in it
what state was it in how did you combine
it how much time
before the next meal and then based on
all these sort of levers you get all
these different effects at the next meal
so like if i ate celery and cucumbers
for one meal
i might accidentally just gorge on the
next meal you'll be starving
yeah yeah yeah you'll be starving but i
see this with my clients all the time
like talking about like no you know your
choices that you make at one meal
are going to directly impact your next
meal and probably several meals after
that
yes yeah where that gets really
interesting is uh in
in fat loss so what you see a lot in in
active fat loss is
i ate perfectly during the day and i
blew it at night and
very common and the reason is that you
have to set up
the evening in the morning so the things
that and again there's good research on
this like there's research showing that
um
if you have an egg at breakfast you're
going to have uh 24-hour total food
intake is going to be slightly less
if you have barley at night you're going
to be
have much greater insulin sensitivity in
the morning if you have a whey protein
preload 30 minutes prior to a higher
sugar meal then you're going to have
lower glucose area under the curve
and so we begin to look at meal to meal
sequencing it's like it's like jiu jitsu
it's like suddenly you have all these
outcomes you can you can produce um a
good example would be
um uh peanuts a small amount of peanuts
together with an orange
as a preload meal you're gonna eat much
less at the next meal because of the
satidi value of both of those so preload
meal will be like 30 minutes
before the the main meal right you're
sort of priming yourself
right to eat less by it it's almost
counterintuitive because like
well i don't want to eat two meals
within a 45-minute window but it's
actually uh it's almost like an
appetizer in a way
well we've been primed to think that the
only variable in the equation is
calories but but really
sometimes you'll actually increase
calories but but to increase calories
you'll increase insulin sensitivity and
you'll decrease total food intake
so it's just really thinking along
different lines that's all but um it's
power
there's a lot of power in doing it yeah
and in eating and threes in particular
um
let's let's talk about a few actually
you know i'm gonna save the niacin and
zinc
uh conversation we're going to be
talking about sleep
in a little bit as well uh nika says
what's the 4-1-1 on vitamins and
supplements
do they help our immune system uh yes
um i i believe that just my my personal
belief that i subscribe to is that food
is the answer right
that food is far more powerful than
anything and that at the end of the day
like
you don't need any vitamins or
supplements if you know how to use food
um that being said vitamins and
supplements are incredibly powerful yeah
they can be very effective using their
supplements though i think we need to
supplement
about the role there linda's question do
pro
probiotics uh do probiotic supplements
really help in any way
that was a very popular question we had
a bunch of people ask this and i know
you're not you're not the biggest fan of
probiotics because they can
they can lead to some some trouble i
just think that the proper place of
probiotics is in the hands of a very
skilled practitioner
um someone like you there's there are
very specific selective applications of
probiotics
that are i would say use the word
miracles
when done correctly but i think that it
takes some training i think it takes you
know experience
um because there are some risks with
probiotics you can you know
the thing i see the most is sibo and i
see that a lot that's small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth
yeah we're kind of in an epidemic of
that you had this period for a few years
where people discovered probiotics and
they went on
all of them and and next thing you know
two three years later everybody's got
gut issues from it but now is that
different with
uh the more natural probiotics so like
something in um
yogurt per say that's an actual food
that has probiotics
uh or sauerkraut things like this that's
different from
the pills and powders right or no yeah
yes
very interesting difference um so the
issue has to do with
um when when things are with food like
let's take the example of yogurt
um they tend to like work in the correct
place in the gut right you're going to
get
you're going to get their fermentation
in the right place in the gut and it's
because
along with though you have along with
the probiotic you have all these
specialized long-chain sugars and
you know different proteins and things
that kind of like help everything work
as a single unit
right when you strip out the other
things and then you're just taking sort
of this selective probiotic there's
there's variables that
you know we can't totally control where
they open up in the gut um
and you might get a host of effects now
that being said you know when you read
the research there's some pretty pretty
amazing things that can be done with
with the right strain of a probiotic for
the right condition and
so again that's why i think that you
know they belong in the hands of
practitioners
and you wouldn't just go willy-nilly to
your nearest whole foods buy out the
probiotic aisle and hope that's going to
fix your gut basically
i would not do that no no i would i
would i would again
just say that you know find a good
practitioner right someone who knows
what they're doing
and and that's a good way to do that if
that's how you want to go man we've got
so much more to get into plus our
listener tips and our added value
segment today
and so many more surprise questions like
how can the strength of one's immune
system be
measured what do different diets like
paleo carnivore
keto and vegan get right and what do
they get very
very wrong plus we have questions about
the top 10 habits to strengthen the
immune system
questions about sleep's essential role
in immunity
questions about why bex has been wearing
tape over her mouth at night
you think it's hot it's not the only
reason though
we have questions about lactose
intolerance and gluten intolerance
questions about how to heal ibs and
ulcers and leaky gut and back pain and
stomach pain and autoimmune issues and a
million more questions for
joel and bex and if you want to hear all
that subscribe to our maximal episode on
the minimalist
private podcast it's a completely
separate
podcast and it's the most honest way for
the minimalist to earn an income because
we don't believe in advertisements by
the way if you're not a private podcast
supporter you're literally missing
two-thirds of our show
because you're a private podcast
listener
why is that it's just it's more casual
and you have a lot more banter between
you and your guests and it just
yeah it's more relaxed yeah and
conversation feels like a it's just a
deeper die
yeah exactly exactly so i like that
though it's more relaxed i didn't
realize that yeah it is
it's good to hear yeah y'all can check
that out head on over to
theminimalists.com
i say try it out for a month i think
you'll get immense value from it it's
worth way more than the two dollars that
it costs
try it out if you don't like it you can
always stop trying it out
right it's like a food you don't like
intimate yeah i think
it's because we're not wearing shirts
during it
the minimalists.com support to subscribe
and get your personal link so that our
private podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app all right
here's some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners hello my
name is amber lee i'm from louisiana
and i wanted to tell you all about um a
company that i find a lot of value in
um it's called united by blue and they
um i'm not getting anything from them
for saying this i just really enjoyed
the company i bought a backpack from
them
a couple years ago and i'm i love it
it's really great and i'm finding a lot
of value in it
they have quality products they're very
environmentally friendly and they take a
pound of trash out of the ocean
for every project that you buy thank you
and thanks for everything y'all do y'all
are great
hi guys um this is trish from
grover north carolina and i'm a
landscaper
and i just wanted to say for you and
also the rest of the listeners on your
podcast
um everybody likes to use a
tire it's shredded up tired it's a
one time mulch they call and it
they advertise it sometimes as a better
alternative
but it is horrible for the environment
it will pollute it
um and over time the mulch
will break down and it'll literally be
pieces of metal attire
in your garden or your bushes or
whatever
so i would just like to discourage
anybody from uh
thinking this is a better alternative
than mulch it was very bad for the
environment
and it is not meaningful at all all
right y'all thanks again to joel greene
for joining us today you can check out
his
new book it's called the immunity code
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes also his website
veep nutrition v-e-e-p
a link to that as well he has some
courses to help you improve your health
there you can also follow him on
instagram he just joined instagram y'all
give him a follow at the real joel green
we'll put a link to his
instagram i think it's just at real
joelgreen
uh we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well for our added value this
week bex
disconsos gardens the botanical gardens
yes we um well we're gonna talk about on
the maximal episode about
getting out in nature and and the key
role and how that helps our immune
system
and um it's nice it's hard especially
live in a city to to get out in nature
but uh this was an opportunity for us to
do so relatively
recently and it's in the middle of the
city but
it doesn't feel like it when you get
there not at all it's
quiet and there's birds everywhere and
lizards and
probably snakes but thankfully we didn't
see any snakes
i think there were fish in some of the
ponds there were
yeah yeah so so i guess if you live in
the greater los angeles area
descanso gardens is a great spot to go
but if you don't
you're looking to get out especially
during these these
weird trying times where we're not under
quarantine but
life is certainly different from what it
was
getting out in nature quite often there
are
just these beautiful botanical gardens
in your city
within a 5 10 20 minute drive of where
you are
we take for granted the places that are
right there
in our backyard growing up in dayton
ohio i think i went
over 30 years without going to the air
force museum and i didn't start going
back there until
i went there i
kept started going back to dayton and
then i would go there all the time after
going back
with who whatever who whoever you were
going with yeah
yeah showing dayton too it's like oh you
gotta go to the air force museum
right which you do yeah it's amazing
right
yeah until you get to the nuclear silos
then it's a little bit depressing
yeah then it's like okay we gotta go now
so avoid nuclear silos and instead
find your local botanical garden i think
that's our added value you did take me
to a botanical garden in dayton though
i did do you remember what that one was
yeah it's in spring bro what's the one
in spring bro sean
it's uh it's right off of 7 41.
i don't know we'll put a link to it in
the show notes that was a good one
all right real quick for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life
of the minimalist sort of bex is
starting a podcast
it's a relationship podcast it's called
how to love and it's
coming out next month in january and i
don't have a link for you right now
actually i'll tell you what the link is
but it's not going to you're not going
to listen to anything yet
howtolove.show will be the link for that
and she's been kind enough
to ask me to co-host with her so i will
tag along
for bex's podcast it's called how to
love it's a podcast about
relationships and sex and parenting
maybe in that order maybe not in that
order yeah emphasis will
shift depending on the episode i can't
wait to have some conversations with you
it'll be awesome
yes it will uh you can follow her on
instagram
minimal wellness and you'll be able to
find more details about when
that podcast comes out you can follow
the minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalist come to one
of our live podcast shows visit
the minimalists.com tour to find a city
near you if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist and if
you want our show notes
in your email inbox sign up for our
email list over at theminimalists.com
and you'll also receive our simple
sunday emails whenever we send
those and if you leave here today with
just
one message we hope it's this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all
we'll see you next
[Music]
every little time you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet
without it